sur ces images satellites des centaines
de véhicules militaires traversé la
petite ville de veliki blanc l'ucl en
ukraine il s'agit d'un convoi de l'armée
russe vraisemblablement en provenance de
la ville de kharkiv un peu plus à
l'ouest kharkiv où la bataille fait rage
selon le gouverneur de la province la
ville et sa banlieue ont été bombardés
près de 70 fois au cours des dernières
24 heures les civils en sont les
principales victimes
j'ai été touché à la tête et l'ondé de
choc m'a projeté en arrière les
escaliers se sont effondrés les fenêtres
et les portes ont explosé c'est un
miracle que j'ai survécu
pas parveen cov plus à l'est ces
ukrainiens savent que l'ennemi russe se
rapproche alors soldats et volontaires
se préparent
fortifications de position préparation
de trancher installations d'obstacles
antichars cette localité rurale pourrait
devenir dans les prochains jours un
immense champ de bataille
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale la
plus grande bataille de chars s'est
déroulée ici et je pense que l'histoire
se répétera à nouveau il y aura beaucoup
de troupes ici ce sera une zone de
combat
en attendant les autorités organisent
des évacuations de civils pour le dîner
et l'ins qui a affirmé samedi que
l'ukraine était prête à se battre et
qu'elle ferait face aux grandes
batailles à l'est du pays
depuis le 25 mars dernier la russie
recentre ses objectifs militaires à
l'est afin de reprendre notamment le
contrôle total des régions séparatistes
de donetsk et de loin sq ce qui
n'empêche pas moscou de frapper d'autres
villes un peu partout dans le pays